maybe if we can begin by talking about
alpha zero and for people who aren't
familiar here what alpha zero is exactly
and how it was able to in a sense teach
itself how to play chess is that a fair
way to look at it but just before we
move to alpha I should say something
involved about deep blue because it's
it's it was not a dawn of artificial
intelligence as presented I mean D blue
was as intelligent as your alarm clock
it didn't have to be intelligent and
it's one of the mistakes we always make
thinking that machine to sort of to
outperform a stitch you do it should be
perfect no it should make few mistakes
services deep blue two out for me and
just and our computers today to
outperform other chess players they
don't have to be perfect so it's not to
out thinkers they do it in in different
fashion but going back to club channel
classification it was still brute force
machine right now that was 20 years ago
with alpha zero is is it's it's a new
new not just new pages
new chapter because while deep blue as
every other computer even just to look
at IBM's Watson for instance they all
you know do optimization of human
generated knowledge so alpha zero just
only got the rules so I emphasize alpha
zero because whether you look at alpha
god or alpha chess they all had this
alpha zero model that allowed them to
actually start from scratch no only the
rules they played against itself so
millions and millions of games and came
up with the own system of evaluation the
overall expectations that conventional
wisdom was that machines getting
stronger and faster and by the way today
the gap between the a chess plank engine
that anybody can buy and download and
his or her in a computer and Magnus
Carlsen sitting world champion is about
the same as between st. Paul's and
Ferrari okay so it's there's no
competition so this is day again not
because they're machines no ever sink
not because the soul this game of chess
it's impossible the number of legal
moves new game of chess according to law
channel himself is ten to the 46 power
but again they make fewer mistakes so
but alpha zero you know it's just it's
again it's it's it's created its own
system of evaluation because it played
60 million games over four and a half
hours and was able to beat stockfish
which for a lot of people
that's one of the best one of the best
chess playing engines yeah it's still in
many questions about a competition
obviously in our stock fish could be
empowered with it with a better hardware
but at the end of the day the difference
between physio and all other chess
playing engines is that alpha0 learn it
on its own
[Music]